[Musique]
[Musique] le
choix du révérend lune est très très bon
[Musique]
étranger
nous ne voulons pas devenir comme le venezuela
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
vous avez besoin de plus que de simples pistolets vous  besoin
de plus que de simples fusils de chasse il faut au
moins
des fusils semi-automatiques
[Musique]
je suis du côté de l'opinion que nous
avons le droit de porter des armes et uniquement
dans le but de protéger et de
défendre nos familles de ne pas faire la guerre
c'est  a c'est une arme de défense pour garder
la paix
amen c'est ça
[Musique]
étranger
m
[Musique]
je voudrais exprimer mes profonds
remerciements
inlassables
au monde